Question came in on Facebook. What is a good herbal for dysmetaria? I had culture a week
a paid every month, whether I have menstruation or not.
There are a lot of different herbals and adaptogens that can help balance hormones. However, you
could, you know, there are a lot of different products on the market that you could just
trial an area. That's what most people do. However, I know I think it's best to test and find
a line. So, getting a Dutch test done would be, I think, the first thing to do. So, if you,
you know, if you were a member of ours, that's what I would push you for to get a Dutch test done
to measure it. I don't know how down that every week, but, you know, the kid, you know, just, I
understand that testing costs money and people are hesitant to spend money to find out what's going
on it, if they're a church as a pay for it. And I understand that struggle. But I also understand
that if we just throw a dart at a dart board, we may hit it, we may not. There's a lot of different
herbals on the market for balancing hormones. If you're going to go that route, I would start with
some adaptogens to see if you can balance your hormones that way. But the best way to do this is to
know what you're doing. So, you only know what you're doing is if you run some lands. So, getting a Dutch
plus done or a Dutch complete done, and you can get that through our courses on our website,
you can order that and measure your hormones. So, you're measuring your estrogen, your progesterone,
your allergens, and, you know, all the, and the cortisol's. So, you really get a measurement. It's
going to be the best way to go. I'm sorry, I don't have like a, I'll just take this and it's going
to solve it. And, quite honestly, you guys, every leery of somebody that says that, at least that says
that a lot. But there are some things that, you know, you could, you could say that for. I have a
digesting issue that I know I have decreased HCl. What should I do? Well, you should take HCl, right?
It takes a digestive enzymes. When you talk about we don't really know really what's going on,
it's better to test. I mean, a person could have dysmetaria, and they have hybrids, you know, so,
how do you know that? Unless you do some tests and you look at some lab levels, also good to get a
CDC, make sure you don't have adenia issues going on. That would point to something like that's more
serious, like a fibroid, or a, or a varietist or something like that. You want to make sure that,
well, you don't, you want your doctor to be thorough, right? You don't want me to give you
answers that are, they're all easier. So that's what I would do, is to always measure if you could
possibly give them.